Hello and welcome.
It's July 29, 2023, and we're here in session three discussion of the course physics's Information Processing at the Active Inference Institute.
We're having a follow up discussion on Chris Fields's third lecture on quantum reference frames, and we're looking forward to your participation.
So if you're watching along live and you've been invited to the calendar event, it's not too late to jump in.
If you're watching on YouTube, you can write any questions or comments in the live chat with Dean and Ander here.
We're going to be looking at some of the key points and taking it in a few different directions, sharing our reference frames, making a shared one.
So, Ander, would be awesome to have you Zoom in a little bit on the slide and then feel free to take us through some of the key points so that we can see a little bit how you're seeing it.
Thank you.
That looks good.
Yes.
Okay, so let's start by reviewing the last lecture from a couple of weeks ago, and then we can open up the discussions.
If there's any questions that appear in the live chat, we can address those.
All right.
So lecture 2, Chris introduced this idea of the information processing between systems A and B, where they interact via qubits on a boundary, and they have reference frames that give meaning to this communication.
You want to think of information processing as a communication channel, the way Shannon thought about it.
So that was in lecture 2.
And lecture 3, a couple weeks ago, tried to make this more explicit by emphasizing the idea that this has to be physically embodied somewhere.
Okay.
And I think that because we are so used to information being fungible in no small part because of the Internet and everything, it's a little hard to understand at first when the claim is made that you have a QRF that is not fungible or you have a piece of quantum information that's nonfungible or things like the no-Cloning theorem.
We're so used to information being fungible, to "it" being zeros and ones, that it's a bit of a change in mindset at first, but that's exactly what lecture 3 introduced.
This was old stuff, right?
Could you maybe just unpack that a little bit?
What would it mean for information to be fungible?
Or what's that stance like?
And then, what does it mean for information to be nonfungible?
And what is that stance like?
Yeah, I'm out to get there.
So let me scroll down the slides, because that's addressed here.
So maybe I should have kept this in the beginning, but anyways, session 2 talked about how information theory makes this simple and obvious.
Okay.
And in session 3, we talk about reference frames and mechanistically, how all of this works.
So, yeah, let's address that question of the difference between... hold on 1 second.
Let me use my mouse to scroll down here.
Okay, so that's a little faster.
Right.
Okay.
Can you restate your question, Daniel?
Yeah.
What would it mean for information to be fungible or nonfungible?
People might be familiar with that in the economic setting with nonfungible tokens and all of that, but what are we talking about with informational fungibility?
I think it basically comes down to whether you can replicate.
I mean, it's basically the difference between classical and quantum information.
As far as I know, fungible information is everything that you can basically turn into a message of zeros and ones.
How you transmit it may be different, the channel, the physical hardware and so on.
But at the end of the day, it's something that you can write on a boundary and something that you can transmit at zeros and ones.
Whereas quantum information, you literally have to send the hardware, the piece of hardware, the QRF.
At least that's how I understand it.
So a simple answer might be that it's information encoded in a piece of software versus a piece of hardware.
But I don't think that analogy is perfect.
Yeah.
Dean, what do you think?
Here's what I'm curious about.
And again, you guys can help me with this.
As opposed to reference frames, I oftentimes default to frame of reference.
And I know that in one of the live streams, what I tried to bring out was the idea that there was an ice cream cone looking at an ice cream truck.
And the question was always whether or not which one of those two entities, one is in the foreground and one is in the background.
And in this slide that Ander has up the question is, is the nonfungibility because only A and B can decide whether the VA as seen by B, the A is deeper into that image based on our frame of reference.
And the B is closer or is the B the one that's actually deeper and the A is the one that's in the foreground?
And I was wondering whether the idea of noncopyability is because of that depth of field aspect that cannot be determined unless it's literally handed over the way that Chris was describing it.
I think that's basically accurate. I'm not sure that I can answer your question, but I think I have the feeling that Chris well, Chris said this in the lecture, that at the end of the day, the QRF is somewhere in your nervous system.
And here, you bring up a good point.
Right.
It looks like this slide is a bit of an optical illusion.
Whether you see A or B deeper, I guess it depends on something going on inside your head.
This picture is so symmetrical that if you focus enough on it, you can change your opinion.
Just to even connect that to what we're talking about.
The classical fungible information on the Holographic screen, on the blanket, and then the quantum cognitive rotation, is those two images are on the screen, identical.
And then whether it gets a quantum rotation such that the three points of the axes are closer to us than the intersection on that kind of tetrahedron or the other way around, whether the ballerina is rotating one way or the other, that's not on the boundary.
So the information about the depth of field is part of the QRF or part of the enactment of the QRF, and it's not written on the boundary.
And that goes back to the preparation question and not just the measuring.
Yeah.
Like if the preparation...if your whole enculturation or the last five minutes, it was entrained, or you were holding an object, that predisposed you to think that the vertex of the intersection was further away, that's the preparation that sets your prior so that when you get this ambiguous artifact, you rotate it into the most natural position, cognitively, and that's the preparation that sets you up for a measurement.
No measurement can happen without a preparation.
What do you think, Ander?
Sure.
Yeah.
Everything you said makes sense.
So perhaps let me recall, what was that, around the slides, it was in this whole spirit or philosophy of making, emphasizing that information is physical, it concubit [?] this whole thing.
One of the glaring omissions in physics was the embodiment of the reference frame, which was treated as an abstraction in classical physics, such as by Galileo, but maybe even Einstein, even if he, my hunch, is that he did have more of this instinct,  particularly in all those thought experiments of trying to chase the light ray.
You are chasing the light ray.
Right.
I mean, this is the whole process of making the observer and the reference frame more and more explicit and more and more physical.
Because at the end of the day, it has to right.
If you start with this assumption, that solipsistic assumption almost, that all you see is part of the same material ether that you are, then you are part of the universe and you're observing something that is out there.
So you need to include a theory of what it means for you to be observing that.
Right.
And at the end of the day, the observer has to be physical.
That's what was emphasized by Chris at the beginning of this lecture.
So this jump from treating the reference frame as an abstraction to a real physical entity...these people have talked a lot about in these papers that are quoted there [2007, Reference Frames, Superselection Rules, and Quantum Information, Bartlett SD, Rudolph T, Spekkers, RW].
But I should also remark, if folks want to see this, it's coming up in high energy theory.
Also in recent work of Susskind [Leonard Susskind] and others, where they talk about quantum reference frames very explicitly.
So I don't have the citations at the bottom, but it's definitely becoming an important thing in the last 20 years, this attempt to really explicitly treat the reference frame and the observer as a quantum entity, as a physical entity.
Okay, so that's what I just said the jump from treating things reference frames as abstractions to physical objects.
And because we cannot make a perfect copy of quantum information, we say that these are unique and nonclonable and nonfungible.
So in order to recreate an experiment perfectly, this is addressed as a part of fungibility or not.
Right.
Can Alice, if you have some sort of quantum experiment and Alice and Bob are, you know, it's the usual DPR [?] thought experiment or whatever, Alice and Bob are separated by light years.
Is it enough, if they want to recreate the same, exact same experiment for Alice to send a string of zeros and ones?
Well, if you had an experiment where that's enough, then you can recreate it with fungible information.
If not, then you need to somehow send nonfungible information, which really implies sending a piece of hardware.
Can I add another piece here on the previous slide?
So this looks really technical and scientific, but let's think about Alice's laboratory; is Alice's brain, mind and Bob's analogously?
Alice is thinking about what to say and then says it.
And that information might be written in a chat form.
It might be said verbally, it might be transmitted through digital or analog signal.
But at some point it's going through this classical informational interface.
And then Bob's laboratory is like perceiving and unpacking it.
And the question of semantic alignment is such that if Alice gives a shopping list of ten items, if there's semantic alignment, Bob would be able to go to the store and then find those ten items.
And it made me think of the dictionary definition of left and right.
So this gets back to our discussion of whether the vertex on these axes is coming towards us or away from us.
So I looked up the dictionary definition of left: "on, toward, or relating to the side of a human body or of a thing that is to the west when the person or that thing is facing north."
So that's, I guess, one attempt to anchor what it means to be left.
The second definition is the left hand part side or direction.
And you could imagine there's an analogous definition for right.
The point is you can't describe verbally leftness and rightness or chirality in general because its reference is an embodied perspective.
And so if Alice said, okay, you're going to go down the street and then turn left at the stop sign, how would Alice communicate to Bob what leftness meant at that stop sign versus rightness?
And that's this question of flipping.
And the way that the quantum formalism accommodates that is through the Wick rotation and the quantum cognitive event where the fungible transmittable holographic information gets rotated into the imaginary axis with the formalisms that enable it to be rotated at all.
But that means you could rotate it "left" or rotate it right.
Yeah, I think that's a very good explanation.
I don't know if I have much to add.
Dean you wanted to say.
I can't.
I don't know the answer to this, but to take what Daniel just said, to take the basic concept of being able to take something that, for all intents and purposes, can appear one way or another and then turn that into how Chris closed the last lecture with we are seeing ourselves as both being entangled and also being separatable.
How did we go literally from a three dimension vertex to we're both entangled and we're not living in a paradox.
That's just the way it is.
We're also removing ourselves or separating ourselves at the same time.
That's what I would like to know, because somewhere between three arbitrary lines and complexity is not a paradox.
Something has to be happening, and I'm not exactly sure how that transition plays out.
Anybody want to enlighten me?
Can you repeat your question, please?
Well, how do we go at this point of the reference frame description of saying, you can't copy it, all you can do is pass it?
Because we think things could be flipped based on internal reference frames, internal meanings and internal models.
The thing we choose for context.
Yada yada yada yada goes all the way out to the conclusion of Chris's conversation with us in number 3, where he said, bottom line is that it's not a paradox that as things become more and more complex, then it wants to get to a place of entanglement, alignment, a sense of agreement, and at the same time wants to remain separate.
So between those two things, a whole lot has happened.
And I don't think we've skipped over it, but we certainly haven't opened it up and really looked at it closely.
And I'm just curious what's in between those two scales.
I agree.
I think we're going to cover that towards the end of the talk, but I agree.
I don't know how you see this related to QRFs or the stuff we just talked about, but I think it's the big question in this lecture, right, that was like, where does this tension between increasing complexity and wanting to predict what the environment is doing?
One requires entanglement and the other one requires separability, at least colloquially speaking, I think this tension is basically what the free energy principle comes down to.
Right.
Daniel, what do you think?
You have the free energy and you have the E minus tS.
One is prediction error.
I mean, not exactly E minus tS.
Right?
That would be thermodynamics but you know what I mean.
One is prediction error and the other one is what was?
I can remember.
I'll definitely look forward to the technical unpacking that you'll get to soon, but I was reminded of the William Blake quotation, "do what you will, this life's a fiction and is made up of contradiction."
So let's modify that: "project what you will, rotate what you will, spacetime's a fiction."
Not that it's false, but that it's a projected fictionalization that it doesn't have the ontological primacy that the topology of communication does and is made up of contradiction.
Yes.
And it's made up of this tension between fitting and not overfitting, between aligning and the principle of unitarity and differentiating and becoming through others, we become ourselves and that type of articulation and recognizing that two complementary forces like convex and concave come into existence at once.
Like a zero to two jump is not an issue or a stumbling block.
It's that we wouldn't have it any other way.
Couldn't have it any other way.
Yeah, sure, we'll get that.
Towards the end, you can almost even call it a duality.
It's not far fetched.
I mean, it's the sort of thing that I think most people will be happy to take for granted.
Such supersymmetry like you have two kinds of particles, but the same amount of them, and dualities that are all over the place.
So I think it's not unreasonable to just accept that there is a tension between increasing complexity, which you want A and B to be separable for, and accuracy prediction.
Now, how this is related to emergent space and these QRFs stuff, I don't want to make very far fetched claims.
We'll talk about emergent space later on the course.
But for now, let's say a few more words about QRFs and then we'll get to the complexity stuff towards the end.
QRFs are almost building blocks, if you want, for information processing. Here, it's very useful to recall the definition that I feel, I think, we have mentioned before, of information as being differences that make a difference.
That's probably the best colloquial definition of information I've heard.
And I think it does a lot of work.
I mean, it's almost mathematical, but anyways, we need to unpack it a little more and see.
So for a difference to make a difference, what do you want out of QRF?
Right.
Unsurprisingly, I mean, not surprisingly, but reassuringly, I think would be the word.
You need a QRF to have sensory, action and a default state, right?
This is sort of like where your Bayesian prior distribution is encoded.
These three things will give you a building block for any information processing.
And that ties together with all the work in the free energy literature and perception-action loops and whatnot.
So before we see mathematically how a QRF is defined, I think it's more illustrative.
And I think Chris went exactly on the right order when he presented this a couple weeks ago, seeing examples from each.
These are actual pieces of hardware that are effectively QRFs, and it's remarkable how they map to...well, I'll skip ahead a little bit.
But when you get to the mathematical definition of a QRF as a quantum system that you can specify with this category theory diagram, you have incoming arrows into a node that then expands.
Right?
And this roughly corresponds to measurement and preparation degrees of, not degrees of freedom, degrees of freedom would be the same, right, when you attach it to the boundary.
But measurement and preparation stages, I guess, would be the better word.
But anyways, let me go back to these examples, right?
And Daniel, you're the biologist here, so correct me if I say anything wrong here.
You have a cartoon picture of a bacteria, I think, and this is a very simple sort of thing, right?
It navigates in the direction of food and that's it, right?
So it is a very simple rudimentary example of a cureb.
You have the sensory stage here, I guess the degrees of freedom.
It's not obvious here what the boundary is, that's one thing.
But it is a good enough picture to see the resemblance to here we have the measurement which in this case you're trying to measure concentration of food.
You have your node here, C, which is your prior distribution for concentration of food.
And finally you have the output, the preparation stage, which is the rest of this chemical network that will control and steer this bacteria, right?
So here you want to call it the action degrees of freedom that will steer this bacteria in the direction of food.
And likewise with cell division, this I understand even less that the network appears more complicated.
But I think it's fair to say that at the end of the day, all these chemical networks that appear super complicated somehow have to be mapped to this category theoretical diagram.
That's all there is to it.
You're going to have the sensory input and the action output and you're going to have the default chemical concentration which amounts to this node over here.
You remember this from last lecture, right, Daniel?
Yeah.
In the Cone-Cocone we explored also in the live stream 17 on the Bayesian semantic information flow.
But I'll kind of add a point about these biological systems in relationship to artificially specified systems and what that helps us understand about perception, cognition, action.
So the cone Cone-Cocone diagram has this bow tie architecture or this kind of like two pyramids touching point to point where there's a preparation and a measurement which can be different dimensionalities or different scopes.
Like it could be multi-input, multi-output or multi-input, single output, vice versa and so on.
But they come through this eye of the needle with C prime here.
Now, contrast that kind of architecture represented here abstractly, with what we see in the bacterial process and in the cell division process.
These have that kind of a bow tie perception, cognition, action architecture or measurement, cognitive integration, preparation architecture.
In contrast, we see, for example, an artificial neural network where the input and the output layers are usually lower dimensional, maybe an image coming in with several hundred pixels and a single output like a classifier coming out the other end, but a dimensional explosion in those internal cognitive layers.
But in biological systems, it's actually exactly the opposite.
For example, many, many receptors on the cell surface, on the holographic boundary, the sensorium of the cell but then there are these common secondary messengers that many pathways converge upon.
So that reflects the kind of radically different architecture that a QRF embodies, as opposed to the approach taken by disembodied intelligence frameworks which use dimensional explosion internally to try to categorize and classify and find edge cases versus this dimensional winnowing that is reflective of these embodied intelligences.
And if I may make a tangential comment here also, I think the good thing about these two examples is that they also showcase the fact of how the deep implications of scale -ree biology, if you want to call it this way.
We tend to think of these sorts of processes, such as here, only happening at the level of the nervous system in animals, or as you said, neural networks.
Right.
We tend to associate this with neural networks.
And perhaps evolution has tiered us in a way that endowed us with nervous systems to make these things.
Maybe these are higher up in the layers, but really that's a bit of an arbitrary distinction that we make.
The processes going on at the cellular level, even if they don't appear to have anything to do with nervous system, my understanding is that there are some generic properties that are the same and everything that has to do with information processing. It manifests maybe slightly different when it comes to explicit neurons, but at the end of the day, it's the same generic process going on.
Would you say?
That's right, Daniel?
The ontological claim is that it's the same generic process happening, whereas the more instrumentalist claim is that we can model it with some shared abstractions.
Yeah.
Okay, so we can continue.
Right?
I don't have a whole lot to say. Daniel said quite a bit. At the end of the day, QRF, you can visualize it as this diagram, and you can think of it, if you are more familiar with the picture of a neural network, and ways on a neural network and so on.
That's the way to think about it.
Now, let's continue with explicit embodiment, if you wish.
So QRFs in the formalism have to be attached to a boundary; boundary degrees of freedom.
And I should add another remark here, and personally to me also, the hard part about this quantum free energy principle formalism, if you wish, is what you said at the beginning is the fact that it's topological, right?
So very often it's not clear what the boundary degrees of freedom are.
Right?
Because we tend to think of boundaries as geometrical and certainly the classical FEP treats them as geometrical.
But that's not the case here in the quantum free energy formalism where we have emergent space will be talked about in later sessions.
But that's just like one quick remark to make at the end of the day, though, even if it's topological, we're going to have real degrees of freedom that this QRF is attaching to this Cone-Cocone diagram.
And you're going to have measurement operators that yield classical outcomes plus and minus one.
And then you can think of this QRF or more abstractly, this Cone-Cocone diagram as a neural network, if it was acting on those under qubits and then back propagating some sort of action signal preparation.
Okay, let's not forget that Landauer's principle and so on requires that we are mindful of energy constraints on computation.
And that gives us the following picture.
Number 1-we're going to have to use energy from the environment to fuel our computation, to fuel our observation.
That means that right away you cannot use the entirety of your boundary to gather information.
It necessitates an allocation of resources.
Right, here, E is the observed environment, and the blue portion is A [the figure shows 'B'], the thermodynamical sector where you extract free energy and dump heat in order to run this computational process.
And then furthermore, you can have a memory sector where you write things on a boundary, and this takes up energy.
Also, writing information onto the boundary by Landauer's Principle will take up information.
And Chris called this the minimally interested observer because it has a memory sector, and quite minimal here implies that we have at least minimal interest implies that we have more than one layer.
Here, the process of writing things onto a memory sector requires us to have a clock so that we can label those memories in time.
Okay, so we do have time as part of this formalism, just not space yet.
Time has to be internal to the observer.
Just one piece on that, that Chris mentioned.
And as you echoed, time here is an attribute of "some" cognitive systems in terms of their "internal" understanding so that they can sort memories and understand what came earlier or later.
It's not something that's a priori defined externally, which is the case in the kind of spacetime first, now, how do we fit communication into here?
We flip that. We're talking about the topology of communication as ontologically, primal and now, certain kinds of sophisticated agents.
This is not like necessarily true of a rock or a metronome or a particle of a gas, but some kinds of cognitive systems are such that they are able to generate an internal clock concept.
And that doesn't have to be the same thing as what's happening on the wall with Kronos.
This can reflect a purely internal time Kairos that enables observers or interactors that have different clock structures.
And then Landauer's principle helps us arbitrage or connect the informational demands to the energetic or the metabolic demands.
Dean so when I first listened to the lecture, I thought when the term or phrase trade-off was raised, I traditionally have thought of trade-off as kind of a binary.
If I'm picking this, I'm trading-off against all the other things that I didn't pick.
So one or the other or others plural.
But when I saw this, and especially when I heard it in the context of things like degrees of freedom, I began to wonder whether it is because it could sit on either side of that boundary.
It could be a priori or it could be ad hoc or post hoc, a trade-off which prior to this conversation, I just assumed that a trade-off was one or the other.
But essentially what this implies is still a kind of a degree of how much weight you put into it and then you kind of cross a threshold and then you've made your pick, you've completed your trade-off.
Or again, did I misinterpret what I was hearing?
If it's topological as opposed to the more conventional spacetime perspective, can a trade-off be both ad hoc and post hoc, seemingly at the same time?
Very interesting question.
Let us just let it float and continue on, enter.
All right.
Because again, I'll just say this.
If it can be, that would really move us out of the classical realm that would essentially say that anytime we've made a pick, we really haven't made a pick.
There's still a whole bunch of other things that are going to happen that can change whatever that action is that we thought we carried out or enacted.
If we're talking about an internality state, which is what I think we want, I think we want to be able to change our minds.
Let me take that one way, Dean.
The analytical equations of the action-perception loop don't tell us in implementation--like if we're going to write it in code--whether we should use action first, procedurally, to update our observations, or whether we enable our observations to wag the dog and then select action at the end of the loop.
So is it a perception-action loop or is it an action-perception loop?
And those enable a kind of seesaw where sometimes we want what we learn to change what we do and other times we want what we do to change what we learn, and having that kind of a fulcrum or a pivot, and again, to connect it to the vertex popping in and out.
The analytical formalisms inscribed on the screen of the FEP, like the textbooks--they're ambiguous.
Whether we lead with action and have inference follow, or whether we lead with inference and have action follow, or lead with action, have inference follow--whichever one of the combinations there are--and then that trade-off or runoff is broken by specific embodied cognitive agents, that trade-off about the procedural primacy of perception or action can't be broken.
Generically. Right.
MMM.
It certainly makes for a lot of waste heat if you're not careful.
It'd be exhausting a lot anyway.
Okay.
I don't know if we can talk about intent much with this formalism, but, we can take a very descriptive approach to it...and go down here a little more actually, before, I don't want to get ahead of myself.
What I mean by that is whether we can put intent or not in this hierarchy, I don't know if it matters a whole lot, but at least we can talk about it operationally and descriptively and say just like when you have a clock, the clock is just there, right?
If you don't have the clock, you don't have the memory and that's it, right?
And likewise here, if we don't have an attention control compartment, we cannot play with all these QRFs that are noncommutative at the same time.
So if there is no attention control system to begin with, we cannot talk about a system that has noncommutative QRFs.
Meaning here, one presumably goes to memory sectors, the other one goes to environment sectors and so on.
So this is certainly a necessity of the fact that we have different sectors of the boundary being allocated to different purposes, such as environmental observation and memory and so on. Within the environment, it's worth remarking that here, if you think deeply about first principles and what it means to observe an entity, well, you still come down to these differences that make a difference sort of thing.
Right.
Which involves whenever you're looking at the environment, if you're going to identify a system, you need sort of a background that puts the system in context.
So that you can identify the system as something distinct.
I think this, again, is something that we have talked about in previous discussions, where the easiest picture here is something like the speed gauge in your car, where P is the gauge itself that tells you the speed, but it's meaningless without the reference system right, outside of the thing that stays invariant, right?
The context, the background, that gauge moving means nothing to you.
So we come back to this idea of if we think of information as differences that make a difference in terms of first principles, this environment sector that we saw earlier has to be further broken down into pointer and reference states.
Again, this is covered in depth in Chris's papers.
I'm thinking particularly of "Free Energy for Generating Quantum Systems."
And again, just to reiterate this attention-control-staff compartment, which is, by the way, very reminiscent to the hierarchy that was earlier, with the clock arising higher up in the hierarchy, deeper into the layer.
Likewise, whenever you're writing something into an [inaudible], you need to have that clock.
Whenever you are deploying noncommunicated QRFs, you're going to need an attention-control compartment.
And we just described this operationally.
If you didn't have it, then the agent would not be what it is; it could not deploy those noncommutative QRFs.
So, marching on, we'll just end here with QRF alignment and the free energy principle.
Just a few more words.
This is possibly the most interesting picture in this presentation and just we can recall here the possibilities for QRF alignment and how free energy comes into play. In this formalism, we call (a) the trivial interaction.
We call this a thermal interaction.
And then you have a bunch of possibilities, right?
And depending on each possibility, you're going to see things as noise or as in the paper says, nonlocal hidden variables.
The last situation is what we call alignment when we have QRFs of the same size, perfectly aligned.
Recall, I think this would be the situation where you have noiseless classical computation, right?
You have A and B just interacting.
And also this is the situation where, correct me if I'm wrong, Daniel, this is entanglement, right?
Asymptotically once all the curves are aligned, you have entanglement and now we can tie it back maybe to Dean's earlier.
So these two slides conclude the discussion basically and then we can open it up.
So given these possibilities for how QRFs can be aligned, QRFs deployed by [inaudible] can be aligned, and how in each situation you're going to get noise or whatever, then what does the free energy principle say in this quantum setting?
Well, minimizing variational, free energy leads you to entanglements.
So if theorem here, if you are in the picture of (d) here and the QRFs are aligned, A and B are going to be entangled.
Now, there is a tension between this tendency towards alignment as free energy principle will carry you, and observe reality, which is that we're not just a blob of entangled particles.
There is separability and systems are attention between maintaining separability and at the same time being correlated enough to the environment so as to be able to predict it.
And now we can maybe go into a more philosophical discussion about the free energy principle.
I should also say in the last month, just like I talked earlier, QRFs, Lenny Susskind, whose recent paper that talks about QRF led me into a rabbit hole when looking into his recent work and he's talked a lot about complexity.
I'm being very speculative here, so if someone can call me out, that would be good in the comments.
But just skimming through some of his papers, I saw a monograph in 2018 where he talks about complexity and he puts forward this second law for complexity in quantum systems and increased complexity [2018, Second law of quantum complexity, AR Brown and L Susskind], and it is very reminiscent of what's going on here.
You have a tension between systems tending to entanglement, and on the other side of the free energy functional, if you wish, where systems increase in complexity and that necessarily requires that A and B are separate.
So Daniel, do you have any comments at this point?
Yeah, there's a lot to it.
I like that you showed the four possibilities in the image above and said it was one of the most interesting figures.
I agree.
And how to connect this to the classical FEP and also how to see the quantum FEP not as just a second story built on top of the classical FEP which would be kind of like a historical chronological understanding of the theoretical apparatus.
But it's almost like the quantum FEP was like a basement we didn't know about because it gives a broader context.
And though it appeared conceptually several years later in the timeline we understand that doesn't give it a secondary status.
So what it really means for the classical FEP to be kind of like a special case of this actually more generic setting there's just a lot I'm very...
I can wrap it up and then if Dean or you want to say something, we can continue with that.
But let me conclude and this is all I have to say for mean, I'm sure Chris will explain this more in coming sessions and lectures.
But I think the main key differences is in the emergence of space.
How it might emerge from something more fundamental, maybe a tensor network or who knows?
But that's the big difference, right?
And I suppose the quantum free energy principle generalizes the classical free energy principle because it doesn't have this spatial embedding.
Now, this, to me personally and also to folks in the audience for asking questions is probably the hardest part to wrap your head around.
And I foresee interest in those discussions and lectures that deal with the concept of emergent space.
Because every time you try to and I've done this myself I've been thinking about how you could apply this formalism to better known pictures or compared it, for instance, with thermal equilibrium, with relaxation, with thermal equilibrium.
And then you start thinking about, okay, what is the boundary and so on.
It's far from obvious, right?
Because, again, you have to remind yourself that the definition is topological.
So in that regard, I think it might be worth talking about one of the questions that came up that I thought was good and then I can call it a day on this end.
So this question and I think it was the first question asked since the last lecture.
Can you just read the full question and then read the full answer?
Thank you.
The answer, it's number 28 here.
Can you guys see it?
Should I zoom in it a little bit?
It's pretty small, but reading it will be good.
Okay.
So this question I think I've asked myself this question too, maybe in a different way.
But basically it gets to the point of what I was saying earlier, right?
That it would be nice to see how we can use this quantum free energy principle formalism to recover maybe familiar settings such as relaxation to thermal equilibrium via the heat equation.
But that's far from obvious how you do it if your definition is topological, right?
So the question says, "what happens when the agent becomes identical to the environment when the model has been improved so much that it does not differ from the environment."
"Is this a state even possible?"
"Would it be thermodynamical-equilibrium-maximum entanglement?"
Okay, so clearly it's not thermodynamical equilibrium, but I think what the person is asking is maybe if I'm understanding this correctly, they're wondering, okay, so if the free energy principle drives A and B towards entanglement, then it's fair to say that any distinction between them has dissolved, right?
That they have merged into the same thing.
That has to do with this whole definition of philosophical debate of thingness that Karl Friston is a proponent of, right?
What it means for two things to be separate.
Okay, so let's see what Chris said.
"Friston has pointed out that the limit of the classical FEP, the limit of perfect prediction, corresponds to generalized synchrony between system and environment."
"Each sends messages that the other can perfectly predict."
Now, however, it's clear I'm not reading anymore.
I'm making a quick remark here.
I'll continue in a second.
In the classical FEP, it's clear that A and B, even if they are in the perfect limit of the FEP, they remain different entities.
Right?
Because you have that, if you wish, that extra layers of differentiation coming from their spatial embedding.
In the classical FEP that is clear, that if they are getting synchronized, they have not lost their separate identities.
You can always say, well, this is the one that was to the left and this is the one that was to the right.
Pun intended with earlier discussion, right?
You have that extra resource for separating them, if you wish, by virtue of the special embedding, right?
The special embedding is giving you this extra information that allows you to keep track of A and B separately.
So I'll continue.
"This notion depends on the system and its environment being separated and hence distinguished somehow."
"In classical formulations, they are separated in ordinary 3D space, i.e.,they occupy different locations. So they are different because they occupy different locations."
Right.
But if you don't have that geometrical background, then how do you know that they're different, right?
Okay, so I continue.
"The quantum formulation is background free, meaning it assumes no spacetime embedding."
"System and environment do not have different locations, even though they have different sets of degrees of freedom in the overall Hilbert space."
"Here the limit of the FEP is maximum entanglement."
"This does not mean that the system and its environment are identical."
They are different, and they have different degrees of freedom."
Okay, so this is just addresses the question I just posed.
"It means that the joint state is not separable into a system S and environment E."
"Their joint states are no longer conditionally independent."
"This is distinct from thermal equilibrium, which means that they have the same temperature while remaining separable and that their interaction can be characterized as the change of thermal fluctuations, i.e., noise."
So I guess this is a nice warm up for things that are to come.
But I do think that this whole idea of emergent space is going to be possibly one of the most important in the course, and it's going to help the gap between the class and quantum formulations, for sure.
Dean, what's your take on this?
What I saw was that when you have that kind of alignment, that perfect alignment, that was one that was (d) in that diagram, right?
That was one state of a complex state that included an (a) and a (b) and a (c) and probably a whole bunch of other ways that yeah, right.
So that one state where you've got this kind of entanglement isn't into perpetuity.
Like you don't get there and then stay there.
And that's where, I think, the question of separability and complexity...it still works, because just because you've momentarily gotten to a place that we define here as (d) doesn't mean you stay there indefinitely.
You could be swapping around to (b) and (c) and (a) in the next instant.
So at least that holds the complexity piece up.
That moment for however long that moment is.
Where XA and XB are aligned isn't permanent.
So it's not predictable in that sense.
Therefore it is complex.
I still don't know how we get, though, that the closer we get to agreement, the more complex things are.
Unless we're just talking about (d) in this array of (a)(b)(c) and (d) that goes back to that quantum reference frame.
I think, like I said, again, maybe I'm interpreting this wrong, but when I message pass the reason why, I have to literally give it over to the other person and let them have it.
I can't have them copy.
What I'm doing is, because there has to be. I guess that reinforces the separability piece of this as well. The fact that I can't give them a copy, that I can only give them the information, and then they've got to sort of unpack it in their own way of taking it off the boundary.
But again, I struggle with this.
1: I'm guilty as charged, but what I'm trying to do is trying to come up with my own narrative, so that what Chris is saying makes sense to me, as opposed to make sense to the world, which is what Chris is trying to do.
I'll try with another speculative fiction.
So there's a screen between, let's just say, the stage and the audience or whatever.
It's a holographic screen.
And on each side of the screen, there's some embodied object.
1: So that means that it's a volume enclosing object because points and lines and planes are only abstractions.
Every real physical object encloses volume.
And now a light is going to be coming from behind each object facing the screen.
And that's this kind of cone that we're seeing from each side.
It's like the shadow cast by the object.
1: So if the object was a sphere, then it would be projecting down to a circle onto the screen.
If the shape were a cube, it could be projecting down.
And so where the light is positioned is the perspective that that cognitive entity is taking on its QRF.
1: Those lights could move.
So now we have the situation where the two spotlights are moving.
1: Maybe the shapes are staying the same, maybe they're changing too.
And it's like two search lights scanning across this B oval and sometimes they are perfectly locked or there could be a situation where they're perfectly aligned or there could be situations where they're totally disjoint.
1: And each of those situations have different implications for what one entity sees when it looks at the screen.
Maybe like the shadow is the only part where you can see because the rest of it is too blinding or something like that.
And so then if we're in case (a) here where maybe (b) doesn't have a projection or maybe (b)'s projection is totally somewhere else, then (a) is in this solipsistic I'm the active agent interacting within an inert world setting.
1: And (d) is like potentially the computer engineer's classical dream or asymptote, which is like all the data going through the USB cable is just being perfectly noiselessly received.
And then we also get these (b) and (c) cases.
1: But (a) is kind of like the inner world.
(d) is like the perfect communication channel. Then to connect it just to Friston's concept of generalized synchrony, as we've talked about many times, generalized synchrony doesn't mean lockstep.
Two agents could reduce their uncertainty about each other, not by doing the same thing at every time step, but for example, by turn-taking.
And I think that points the way to how we get reduction of variational free energy, reduction of prediction error, surprise and so on without, especially, spatial temporal enmeshment, but not necessarily even informational identity enmeshment, because you could have two things that through their alignment become actually differentiated and that could increase the mutual information between two metronomes,not just to have them going in the same direction, but to have them going in opposite directions.
The mutual information in those two settings is going to be high.
So it's not the case that generalized synchrony means that things are becoming blurred.
We could actually also have integrated information through increased articulation, not just decreased.
1: And then life finds a way or cognition finds a way on this trade-off frontier of, in our pursuit of unitarity, will we blur to unify or will we differentiate to unify?
1: But those are the paths we have.
We don't have the backwards ratchet.
Yeah, yeah, makes sense.
Any other latter slides, Ander?
No, that's it.
So Chris made a few more remarks at the end about language here, but he mentioned that he's going to talk more about this in the coming lecture.
So we'll just leave it up to him.
Yeah.
There could be some very powerful and interesting linguistic opportunities for updating our speaking to reflect what we are learning here.
I don't know what those necessarily are, whether it's a syntactic or a semantic thing, or whether it's a narrative thing, but how to actually reenter some of these formalisms into our focused understanding could just be immensely powerful, and we could have a lot of integrity between the natural language way that potentially we're already showing up for engagement, and some of these formalisms that get to first principles about interacting entities and boundary conditions and all of that.
1: Dean, any penultimate thoughts?
Not really.
1: I'm going to go back and listen to Chris's comments again about this common cause and the fine-tuning assumption and whether that's sort of metaphorically, a dialing-in or what he means exactly by the fine-tuning, in the context of this conversation today, what you just kind of said about are we dulling something here or are we sculpting something to make it more fittable?
I'm going to go now and go back and listen to what he talks about in terms of fine-tuning and maybe update my priors around that.
And are there any last thoughts or maybe scroll over to the schedule of the course again just so we can close on that?
1: Yeah, we're halfway through.
We just completed the third discussion section now, so we've had three lectures and three discussions.
It's all downhill from here.
By the way, this was the first midterm.
You guys both did well.
1: We're going to head into session 4 with these last three, how agents use multiple communication channels and that's going to get connected to the quantum FEP, how spacetime emerges from communication, which is something that we've brought up a bunch, it's been in the background, but making that explicit is going to be exciting.
And then section 6, I think, is just going to be such a jumping-off point because the scope and the intensity of what is transpiring is extreme,so connecting it to biology, which is to say life more fully, and where we go in '23 and beyond, that's going to be awesome.
So, any last words, Ander?
No, I just echo what you said.
I would say it's going to be uphill in terms of how interesting it's going to get, uphill in a good sense, meaning that we're planning.
Cool, well, I encourage people to check out the course website and submit questions that they'd like to see addressed by Chris.
Also to register and join these participatory discussions.
There'll be three more of them, so if you want to join, share your QRF, be part of the publication of all of these works that we'll compile at the end and just get your exoskeleton in the game with what is happening here.
1: It'd be really awesome to hear more voices and to have more on board.
Okay, thank you, Dean, and Ander, till next time.
Bye.